bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public et c'est
parti pour 90 minutes de débat et de
reportage 90 minutes pour donner du sens
à l'actualité grâce à nos invités
experts et dans l'actualité de ce 10 mai
il y a le revirement du gouvernement sur
la loi immigration annoncée par Emmanuel
Macron dans ces 100 jours reportés par
Elisabeth borne faute de majorité et
finalement remise aujourd'hui au
calendrier le texte sera présenté en
Conseil des ministres au moins de
juillet un signe de flottement
révélateur on en débat dans un instant
et puis dans trois quarts d'heure c'est
le fonctionnement le mode de nomination
et l'impartialité du Conseil
constitutionnel que l'on questionnera
parmi ceux qui le défendent il y a le
sénateur LR Philippe Bas
il est le gardien du temps
il fait respecter la règle du jeu
parlementaire elle est inscrite dans la
Constitution et d'autre part réveil à ce
que aucun principe fondamental ne soit
mis en péril par une loi qui vient
d'être votée
il y a un mois les 9 sages validaient
l'essentiel de la réforme des retraites
ont décortique cette décision les
pouvoirs et les faiblesses éventuelles
du Conseil constitutionnel dans le
second débat de ce sens public mais
d'abord ce nouveau caillou dans la
chaussure du gouvernement le Sénat qui
ouvre une commission d'enquête sur le
fond mariage la ministre Marlène
Schiappa va devoir s'expliquer sur
l'utilisation des fonds alloués à la
défense de la laïcité après l'assassinat
terroriste de Samuel Paty Samia de chien
c'était une demande du groupe socialiste
c'est désormais une commission d'enquête
transpartizanes du Sénat après un vote
en séance la chambre haute a décidé
aujourd'hui de se plonger dans les
rouages du fond Marianne un fond créé
après l'assassinat du professeur Samuel
Paty en 2021 par Marlène Schiappa alors
ministre délégué à la citoyenneté
2,5 millions d'euros ont été distribués
à 17 associations pour promouvoir les
valeurs de la République mais fin mars
la presse a révélé que deux associations
ayant chacune touché plus de 300.000
euros aurait utilisé ces sommes à des
fins différents cette couche d'enquête
va travailler sur les conditions de
distribution de l'argent qui a été prévu
sur l'utilisation de ses fonds sur le
résultat qui ont été attendus ont-ils
été obtenu nous vérifierons tout cela
nous verrons bien s'il y a eu peut-être
des fonctionnements anormaux au regard
d'un dispositif qui est financé par de
l'argent public la commission d'enquête
devra tout de même prendre garde à ne
pas marcher sur les plats de bandes de
la justice car le parquet national
financier vient également d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire sur le fond
Marianne pour détournement de fonds
publics par négligence abus de confiance
et prise illégale d'intérêt au titre de
la séparation des pouvoirs le Sénat ne
pourra pas enquêter sur le volet pénal
de cette affaire ce qui relève du pénal
c'est des comportements individuels et
éventuellement des prises illégales
des des
fonctionnements qui seraient comment
dire sans contrepartie par rapport à une
rémunération ou sur fond d'État voilà
les sujets qui relèvent judiciaire nous
on peut en parler on peut en discuter
mais on ne peut pas caractériser la
commission d'enquête cherchera davantage
à établir la chaîne de responsabilité
qui a pu permettre de potentiels
malversations du fond Marianne elle aura
trois mois pour rendre ses conclusions
trois grands chapitres dans ce débat
100% politique le fond Marianne donc la
loi immigration et les manifestations de
l'ultra-droite avec mes invités Bruno
cotreize bonsoir vous êtes politologue
chercheur au CNRS et vipof leur Salvin
bonsoir directrice générale de cantar
publique Jean-Louis Missika bonsoir
bonsoir Jean-Louis directeur éditorial
de la rue vue de terre-nova la grande
conversation et Mathieu croissanto
éditorialise politique bonsoir Mathieu
bienvenue à vous aussi sur le fond
Marianne donc pour commencer Bruno
cotress cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire qui qui ouvre au Sénat
jusqu'où peut-elle fragiliser le
gouvernement est-ce qu'elle peut le
fragiliser au-delà du seul cas de
Marlène Schiappa d'après on se rappelle
que quand le Sénat fait des commissions
d'enquête ça marque souvent l'opinion et
ça peut laisser des trains évidemment le
chef de l'État l'exécutif dans son
ensemble et sur un terrain sur lequel il
avait voulu marquer au fond un vrai
renouveau Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il a
été élu pour la première fois en 2017
d'abord aux raisons de la défiance
politique en France et en particulier
la bonne utilisation de l'argent public
le comportement des élus l'exemplarité
dans le comportement des des élus
n'avait-il pas dit d'ailleurs à ce
moment-là que tout ministre allait
passer en une sorte de d'examen
d'évaluation de l'entretien d'évaluation
annuelle et ceux qui n'avaient pas servi
avait vocation à quitter le gouvernement
donc on voit que l'exécutif et sur un
terrain dans lequel il a voulu incarner
un véritable renouveau avec une option
publique et incroyablement acran sur ces
questions sentiments dans le pion
publique que les élus se servent plus
qu'il ne servent le public donc un sujet
qui est toujours potentiellement très
difficile par ailleurs là il porte sur
une ministre qui est un symbole très
important des débuts d'Emmanuel Macron
elle a été Marlène Chappat véritablement
on peut dire Nikon de la de la macronie
donc effectivement ça va sans doute être
assez visible et la commission d'enquête
parlementaire plus une enquête du
parquet national financier ça ça
financier justement leur Salvin est-ce
que cette affaire qui n'en est cassé
début évidemment présomption d'innocence
on rappelle tout tous les tous les
termes et ce n'est pas seulement une
précaution de langage est-ce qu'elle
infuse elle commence à infuser dans
l'opinion
c'est pas encore si elle commence à
infuser c'est quand même assez récent
voilà malgré tout il y a quand même en
fond malgré tout la réforme des
retraites qui restent encore très
présent dans dans l'opinion quand on
demande aux Français les conversations
qu'ils ont avec leurs proches en famille
avec des collègues etc alors en premier
on a toujours le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation etc en deuxième
les retraites on n'a pas du tout encore
les fonds Mariannes mais comme le dit
comme le disait Bruno en effet c'est
c'est la macronie c'est vraiment
installé sur ce sujet là sur la
transparence sur l'utilisation des des
fonds publics et là elle est un petit
peu abîmée
alors même qu'on sort d'une séquence
politique très dure pour le gouvernement
et pour et pour l'exécutif et puis ça
vient aussi en parallèle avec la mise en
place d'un site internet sur justement
où vont vos impôts comment sont
distribués aux impôts etc donc là
effectivement comment utiliser l'argent
public et bien ça ça entache un petit
peu cette démarche du gouvernement qui
était plutôt justement de dire voilà
nous sommes dans la transparence et puis
vous voyez concrètement à quoi servent
vos impôts et là à nouveau on va ajouter
un petit peu de défiance je dirais dans
l'opinion référence Bruno aux
commissions d'enquête sénatoriales
évidemment on pense à la faire Benalla
Jean-Louis Mika il y a quand même pas
mal de différences en tout cas dans la
proximité avec le le premier cercle et
l'Isère est-ce qu'on peut dire ça oui
oui c'est quand même tout à fait la même
chose je crois que c'est intéressant on
verra ce que donnera cette commission
d'enquête mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est justement qu'on réfléchisse sur la
les décisions politiques qui sont prises
pour répondre à une émotion de de
l'opinion publique et qui sont prises
dans l'urgence en fait ce fond Marianne
a été décidé de façon extrêmement rapide
parce qu'il y a eu l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty et on voit bien que
c'est pour dire que le gouvernement fait
quelque chose chose qu'une décision
comme celle-là est prise avec toutes les
conséquences que ça c'est à dire
ces bricoler c'est fait très vite on
sait pas trop
comment ça va se passer on ne sait pas
trop où ça va et cette politique de
l'émotion en fait c'est une mauvaise
politique et ça ce serait intéressant
que la commission
sénatoriale puisse en tirer un certain
nombre de leçons parce que c'est
malheureusement de plus en plus souvent
comme ça
que se fait la politique absolue
un fait divers une loi quoi c'est une
émotion il y a un fait divers une loi on
l'a tellement vécu et bien on voit on
voit justement les limites de cette
politique précisément ça rend cette
affaire potentiellement dévastatrice
parce que c'est une affaire qui survient
avec un organisme grécier qui est créé
au lendemain d'une tragédie nationale
qui est quand même on peut rappeler déjà
l'assassinat dans des circonstances
absolument dégueulasses à la sortie de
mon collège dans l'enseignant
d'histoire-géo et le percute de plein
fouet en fait plein de symboles à la
fois la défense de la République parce
que cette association elle est quand
même créée pour ça pour défendre des
valeurs républicaines sur notamment sur
le numérique enfin sur les réseaux
sociaux sur sur Internet elle percute
Bruno de la macronique a toujours été un
électron libre dans la macronie Marlène
Schiappa elle fait beaucoup parler
d'elle en bien ou en mal comme on dit a
fait voilà l'essentiel c'est qu'elle
fasse parler d'elle c'était un des
profils les plus politiques d'une
certaine façon on avait bien compris
tout tout ce qu'elle pouvait jouer aux
différents ministères qu'elle a occupé
mais donc il va y avoir toute une partie
de l'opposition qui va vouloir se payer
ce symbole de la macronie ça percute le
mythe de l'efficacité macroniste aussi
c'est on fait des politiques
pragmatiques parce qu'elles sont
efficaces ben non voilà et puis en plus
il y a des si jamais c'est avéré enfin
j'ai ces histoires de vidéos qui
disait des adversaires politiques en
pleine campagne présidentielle avec des
comédiens qui qui étaient là pour les
débiles même ils ont été très peu vu
même si elles ont été très peu diffusés
on a quand même tous les ingrédients
dans ce qu'on a alors après comment
toute la question est de savoir quel
rôle Marlène Schiappa a joué là-dedans
est-ce qu'elles sont les tenues de
lancer l'idée comme elle le dit ou
est-ce qu'elle a choisi des amis pour
pour récupérer les subventions qui
étaient allées l'avenir le dire
évidemment prudent comme toujours sur
ces affaires là mais vous parliez des
critiques de finalement la porte que ça
ouvre des critiques de des oppositions
je vous en propose une celle du premier
secrétaire du PS c'était dans la
matinale de Public Sénat le 17 avril
dernier
c'est un scandale total d'avoir
aujourd'hui une ministre qui en fait a
utilisé la mémoire de Samuel Paty pour
en faire un instrument politicien au
service de ses propres amis et donc oui
il y a un sujet et j'espère que y
compris cette ministre reviendra y
répondre et même dans Playboy elle peut
venir expliquer ce qu'elle a fait de
l'argent bon on rappelle que 17 avril on
est juste après
l'interview de de Marlène Chappat dans
Play Boy je voudrais qu'on passe encore
quelques minutes sur la la personnalité
effectivement politique de de Marlène
Schiappa Bruno cotress bon je vais
ouvrir une porte ouverte là aussi en
disant qu'elle joue peut-être un peu sa
carrière ou en tout cas cette période de
sa carrière avec avec ce fond Marianne
mais c'est peut-être aussi l'une des
ministres qui jouent un peu sa carte
perso depuis quelques temps est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça
en tout cas c'est certain d'abord c'est
qu'effectivement c'est un peu un
carrefour parce que si jamais elle
devait être mise en cause ou que les
enquêtes révèlent qu'elle avait manqué
de vigilance qu'elle avait été
négligeante sans même forcément avoir
quelque chose à se reprocher pénalement
mais qu'elle avait manqué à son à son
devoir on va dire de bons gouvernements
ou de bon administration de fonds
publics c'est sûr que c'est un gros coup
d'arrêt dans une carrière politique
évidemment ce n'est pas forcément la fin
du carpe politique mais c'est sans aucun
doute un gros coup d'arrêt il faut
rappeler qu'elle n'était pas dans un
premier temps revenu dans l'équipe
d'Emmanuel Macron après sa réélection en
2022 qu'elle est revenue ensuite au
gouvernement justement comme une sorte
un petit peu de personnalité qu'on fait
revenir pour retrouver l'état d'esprit
de départ et pour le moment c'est vrai
qu'on n'y est pas on n'y est pas
vraiment les Français
identifient sans doute à peine de quel
portefeuille ministériel elle est en
charge on n'a pas vu vraiment d'annonce
et de d'actions qui sont mettent en très
attachés à son nom contre ce deuxième
mandat dans le premier mandat c'était le
cas mais là dans le deuxième mandat
c'est plus compliqué donc l'économie
sociale et solidaire
un carrefour de ça de ça de sa vie
politique et elle qui pour le moment
avait symbolisé on va dire cette air
frais qui avait été insufflé dans la vie
politique française en 2017 avec des
profils tout à fait tout à fait nouveau
et l'on faisait partie
issus de la société civile de son
engagement sur la question de la défense
des droits des femmes à très vite
trouver sa place dans la macronie dont
elle est devenue vraiment quelqu'un de
extrêmement populaire parmi les
adhérents du parti présidentiel et là on
voit qu'effectivement
c'est peut-être quelque chose de
difficile qui alors justement leur
Salvin sur sa popularité il y a pas
beaucoup de personnalités politiques
très populaires en ce moment on disait
ça la dernière fois où c'est devenu sur
ce plateau et elle se situe où
notre dernière vague du Figaro Magazine
époque en fait elle est à 12% de côtes
d'avenir et c'est quand même assez
dingue quand on pense finalement à la
long activité aussi de son parcours
malgré tout même si il est pas si long
que ça malgré tout ça fait un moment
qu'elle est sur le devant de la scène
etc et elle n'arrive pas à comme
beaucoup de ministres de la macronie à
aller au-delà des 12 15 16% de code
d'avenir c'est-à-dire le souhait des
Français de voir jouer un rôle à
l'avenir pour ces personnalités
politiques et puis je dirais que
l'interview justement dans Playboy a eu
certainement un impact dans l'opinion
aussi on voit qu'elle a perdu trois
points ce dernier mois notamment à
droite auprès des électeurs de droite et
de centres droits on voit
qu'effectivement elle joue un rôle alors
peut-être un rôle personnel mais qui
convient pas forcément et qui qui est
pas forcément aligné à ce qu'attend
l'opinion à son égard et là
effectivement avec cette nouvelle même
si on doit pas toutes les précautions
évidemment nécessaires ça restera quand
même une restera quand même quelque
chose de tout ça une petite quelque part
une image un peu écornée aussi quand
même
avec une défiance peut-être accrue à son
égard donc oui et puis avec Jean-Louis
missiquet on va terminer sur ce chapitre
fond Marianne avec c'est un peu un
boulet qui va qui va freiner pendant un
certain temps la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale va prendre plusieurs
semaines ça va aller au moins jusqu'à
jusqu'à la fin bon jusqu'à l'été donc
voilà c'est c'est une sorte de soupçon
et puis on a souvent analysé ici ou dans
d'autres émissions ensemble la rapidité
du tribunal populaire médiatique voilà
ce ce fond de soupçon il va il va
entacher à la fois le présent de Marlène
Schiappa et puis voilà l'image du
gouvernement général oui mais moi ce qui
me frappe c'est c'est la démarche on a
parlé de l'interview donc Playboy ce qui
est vraiment troublant dans cette
interview de Playboy c'est qu'elle ne
parle absolument pas des sujets de son
ministère économie socialiste solidaire
oui mais qu'elle parle par contre des
sujets d'une autre ministre puisque de
son ministère précédent
et et on voit bien à quel point il y a
comme ça une dissociation en quelque
sorte entre la personnalité médiatique
et le rôle politique le statut politique
de la de la personne c'est à dire que ce
n'est plus une ministre c'est une pipole
et donc on est assez rude dans votre
dans votre analyse mais bon pourquoi pas
je l'entends mais est-ce que est-ce que
parce que le côté carte perso je
reprends la formulation que j'utilise
tout seul
peut-être qu'elle sait aussi une période
un peu de flou on va en parler là dans
les deux prochains débats qui domine en
ce moment est-ce qu'elle profite d'une
période de fou pour jouer cette carte
perso ou est-ce que finalement c'est un
peu ce qu'elle a fait même dans le
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
non mais elle a toujours joué cette
carte perso mais dans le premier
quinquennat il y avait quand même une
tentative un effort d'adéquation entre
entre son rôle politique et son et son
statut médiatique là il y a une
dissociation complète c'est juste cela
que je voulais dire c'était quelque
chose c'est c'est on voit que il y a un
côté en quelque sorte peut-être chez
certains ministres de réflexion sur le
coup d'après ce qu'ils feront après leur
leur passage leur passage dans le
ministère et donc oui vous avez raison
par rapport à cela cette affaire de du
fond Marianne représente un handicap
poil
sentiment de flottement je le disais on
y vient renforcer par cette valse
hésitation sur la loi immigration ce
matin l'issue du conseil des ministres
le porte-parole du gouvernement se
défendait de tout revirement sur ce
texte le projet de loi il sera présenté
en Conseil des ministres au mois de
juillet à l'issue d'une concertation qui
a été confiée au ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin à qui les confier donc
cette mission de chercher du consensus
et de trouver du consensus dans les
prochaines semaines pour que ce projet
de loi pour réformer le système
d'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
dans notre pays puisse être présentés
dans les meilleures conditions à
l'automne donc il y a une précision sur
la méthode et le timing mais aucun
revirement
et j'accueule Mathias Arès bonsoir
Mathias bienvenue cette nouvelle
migration qui a connu on va dire
quelques montagnes russes absolument
refait le match allez depuis des mois en
évoquait un projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
portée à la fois par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin et le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
alors premier février le PJL est
présenté en Conseil des ministres mi
mars en pleine discussion sur les
retraites au Palais du Luxembourg la
commission des Lois du Sénat examine le
texte et là il y a des premiers remous
la majorité sénatoriale de la droite et
du centre qui n'est pas d'accord en son
sein durcit le texte la suite on la
connaît le texte est l'une des premières
victimes collatérales de la crise
politique soulevée par la réforme des
retraites le président de la République
en concertation avec le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher décide finalement
d'ajourner son texte dans un contexte
jugé trop abrasif alors nos
téléspectateurs sont des assidus de
l'actualité parlementaire PGL évidemment
c'est le projet de loi on l'avait tous
compris à ce stade le texte n'est pas
abandonné pour autant non dans le texte
est bien reporté à ce stade mais c'est
la méthode qui devait changer Emmanuel
Macron voulait découper le texte le
fameux saucissonnage dénoncé par les
sénateurs sans donner plus de précision
sur le calendrier alors saucissonner
puis plus aussi sonné il a fallu
attendre plus d'un mois en tout cas le
discours d'Elisabeth borne le 26 avril
dernier pour entendre un nouveau parler
du dit texte on l'écoute
ça n'est pas le moment de lancer un
débat sur un sujet qui pourrait diviser
le pays
nous allons donc continuer les échanges
pour trouver un chemin autour du projet
de loi et si nous ne pouvons pas trouver
d'accord global nous présenterons en
tout état de cause un texte à l'automne
avec comme seul boussole l'efficacité
bon et donc là encore c'est un peu
ratéro virement on va dire c'est encore
raté voilà l'information est tombé mardi
soir ce sont nos confrères du Figaro qui
l'ont donné Matignon aurait donné son
feu vert à Gérald de Darmanin en lien
encore avec Olivier dussobe au travail
et Franck Riester aux Relations avec le
Parlement pour redémarrer la machine et
relancer les consultations en vue de la
présentation d'un texte en conseil des
ministres courants juillet l'examen au
Parlement devrait lui toutefois bien
avoir lieu à l'automne mais il y a
plusieurs questions qui subsistent et
que est-ce que c'est l'accord entre les
LR du Sénat et les LR de l'Assemblée sur
des textes d'immigration qui a conforté
le gouvernement dans son optique de
faire voter un texte et puis également
une dernière question subsiste est-ce
que cette fois la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée pour
raconter sur des LR fiables pour voter
son effectivement ça c'est une question
essentielle merci Mathias et on va y
venir évidemment avec nos invités tiens
je commence avec vous Bruno cottre
est-ce que dans cette valse hésitation
vous y voyez quand même des différences
stratégiques de point de vue stratégique
entre l'Elysée et Matignon est-ce qu'il
y a pas d'abord ça peut-être que ça
peut-être que ça c'est pas c'est pas
impossible encore que la première
ministre quand on réécoute comme on l'a
fait à l'instant ses propos on voit que
ses propos peuvent être assez facilement
récupérés aujourd'hui pour dire ben non
il y a pas de changement de méthode le
porte-parole du gouvernement il y a pas
de changement de l'automne on parlait de
l'automne on parlait d'un chemin pour
arriver à voir s'il y a des convergences
possibles donc une parole de la première
ministre qui était suffisamment large au
fond pour que tout le monde arrive à
dire que ça ça cadre avec ce qu'elle
avait avec ce qu'elle avait annoncé il
faut plutôt retenir je pense le
sentiment d'abord et avant tout un peu
d'un d'un pilotage qui est difficile à
bien cerner sur cette question entre
c'est plus d'actualité ça va être ceci
ce n'est mais non c'est pas saucissonner
et il faut trouver des consensus il faut
afficher des convictions en même temps
quoi on a quand même le sentiment un peu
d'un pilotage à vue sur une question qui
est pourtant un point capital du
régalien et sur lequel il y a plus que
plus que conflit d'opinion conflits
d'interprétation dans la dans la société
qui est un thème qui est toujours un
thème assez potentiellement explosif peu
politiquement alors double question leur
Salvat vous avez en partie répondu tout
à l'heure mais l'immigration et se place
sous dans les préoccupations des
Français puis ensuite peut-être sur une
Elisabeth borne qui cherche depuis
quelques semaines à faire entendre sa
propre musique jouer un peu sa carte
sur l'immigration elle se situe à peu
près entre 5e et 6e priorité des
Français donc à nouveau on a
l'impression d'un petit décalage quand
même malgré tout aussi par rapport à la
priorité absolue des Français qui
restent le pouvoir le pouvoir d'achat et
puis comme le disait Elisabeth band dans
dans son discours c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet qui attise les tensions les
Français considèrent effectivement
une grande majorité de Français
considèrent que on ne peut pas parler
sereinement de ce sujet aujourd'hui en
France donc effectivement je pense qu'il
y a une certaine appréhension à
appréhender le sujet c'est pour ça qu'on
avait le sentiment je reviens sur la
question de voilà de de différentes
stratégies d'utiliser votre banque qui
cherchait à calmer le jeu avec un
Emmanuel Macron qui au contraire dit 100
jours enfin voilà je veux donner un
peut-être plus un sentiment
d'accélération un sentiment
d'accélération et puis surtout il veut
vraiment balayer la séquence des
retraites il veut faire oublier on a
vraiment l'impression en ce moment que
le gouvernement est c'est de de de
comment dire de tirer toutes les
ficelles possibles pour qu'on puisse
voilà passer à autre chose aller de
l'avant être ce gouvernement et incarner
ce gouvernement qui avance qui est dans
le progrès c'est d'ailleurs c'était
d'ailleurs dans le dernier discours de
d'Emmanuel Macron à cette France qui
avance à part que les Français sont un
petit peu en décalage avec cette idée de
d'avancer absolument donc c'est un peu
compliqué et d'accord parce que je
repose la question sur une première
ministre qui qui joue un peu sa carte ça
rejoint ce que disait peut-être
Jean-Louis Sica tout à l'heure sur des
ministres qui pensent à la presse que on
peut dire ça aussi d'Élisabeth band je
sais pas si elle pense à la parce que je
trouve qu'elle est pas très politique en
tout cas il allait pas perçue par les
Français comme une femme très politique
elle est perçue comme une femme très
technicienne très experte très
travailleuse très sérieuse aussi mais
elle est pas perçue comme une femme qui
a une ambition en tout cas pas jusqu'à
présent politique donc je sais pas quel
carte elle souhaite jouer en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'elle joue la carte
aussi ben de la technicien je sais ce
qui est possible de faire et je sais ce
qui n'est pas possible de faire c'est
plutôt ce cette carte là de l'experte en
fait plutôt que de la politique est-ce
qu'elle est pas plus politique qu'on le
qu'on ne le pense finalement je pense
qu'elle est un peu plus politique qu'on
ne qu'on ne le dit et l'opinion la
perçoit absolument c'est à dire on voit
bien d'ailleurs quand elle parle d'un
sujet qui qui divise et qui peut qui
peut crisper et qui peut crisper
l'opinion moi ce que je pense surtout
sur cette affaire c'est que on retrouve
toujours la même question c'est comment
gouverner quand on n'a pas de majorité
au Parlement c'est toujours la même
question c'était la question de la
réforme des retraites et ce sera demain
la question de
de cette loi sur sur l'immigration et on
voit que il y a certainement peut-être
entre le Président de la République
Gérald Darmanin Elizabeth borne des
nuances
sur
comment faire pour gouverner sans
majorité absolue on y reviendra ça parce
que c'était le thème notamment d'un
article que vous avez signé dans dans la
grande conversation Mathieu peut-être la
fin d'une d'un espoir pour le corps
Macron et d'une période qui était le
fameux les fameux joueur et en même
temps les fameuses lois stéréo vous
savez avec une partie pour contenter la
droite une partie pour contenter la
gauche comme ça on fait voter le premier
bout par la droite le premier le
deuxième bout par la gauche en fait ils
sont perçus que à vouloir contenter tout
le monde on ne satisfait personne et au
contraire que les mécontentement
s'agrégaient et donc que ça faisait
foirer les projets de loi donc ça
visiblement c'est terminé et l'objectif
et donc ça veut dire que pardon 21 le
texte il va être vidé de la partie du
soft en particulier
l'exécutif le compte plus sur la gauche
sur les voies éventuelles de gauche pour
voter vous la fameuse expérimentation
qui voulait qu'on régularise des
sans-papiers dans des secteurs en
tension en manque en manque de main
d'oeuvre ça c'est ce rêve là en tout cas
est terminé après ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il y a les républicains qui disent
eux ils sont bien décidés enfoncer un
coin sur ce sujet qui met mal à l'aise
le pouvoir et donc ils veulent déposer
deux propositions de loi et donc le
pouvoir n'a aucune envie de se faire
doubler sur cette question là par les
républicains prix de se faire prendre en
défaut sur ce sujet puisqu'on sait qu'on
accuse souvent Emmanuel Macron de ne pas
s'être occupé de ça et entre nous c'est
quand même on le rappelle il faut le
rappeler à chaque fois la 21e loi je
crois en 30 ans sur les migrations de ce
point de vue là le nouveau monde fait
exactement comme l'ancien Gérard Collomb
lui-même avait porté une loi immigration
asile en 2018 chaque quinquennat une loi
sur l'immigration on est vraiment dans
un schéma répétitif alors sans doute les
problématiques changent-elles parfois
d'un Quinquin à l'autre mais pas
toujours il y a aussi une très claire
volonté d'affichage alors
toi qui me paraît essentiel c'est que la
thématique de l'immigration c'est la
thématique du rassemblement national
c'est la thématique de Marine Le Pen et
donc la question de savoir si aller sur
ce terrain là c'est faire le jeu du
rassemblement national ou entrer en
compétition et donc lutter contre le
rassemblement national est une question
qui divise aussi je pense une partie du
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs c'est une
thématique mais peut-être tellement
intégré par les Français que Marine Le
Pen a presque plus besoin d'en parler
vous voyez ce que ce que je veux dire
justement moi je crois qu'on est en
train aussi de reproduire ce que le ce
qu'on a fait pour la réforme des
retraites c'est à dire que on n'explique
pas aux Français pourquoi on s'attaque à
ce problème ou cette problématique de
l'immigration pourquoi il y a besoin
d'une loi alors qu'on en a voté avec ça
pour pour résoudre quel problème quel
problématique en fait sur la réforme de
retraite c'est vraiment le péché
originel c'est-à-dire que on n'a pas
expliqué enfin en tout cas le
gouvernement n'a pas réussi à expliquer
pourquoi maintenant il fallait agir sur
les retraites et là le gouvernement est
en train de faire exactement la même
chose c'est à dire on ne sait pas il y a
une loi sur l'immigration mais enfin bon
pour quelle raison et pour quel objectif
on n'a pas on n'a pas les réponses oui
d'ailleurs je trouve que c'est vraiment
le problème central aujourd'hui de la
communication de l'exécutif le sentiment
qu'on a ouvert tellement de dossiers il
y a tellement d'annonces qui ont été
faites depuis 20 ans plusieurs semaines
avec un tel empilement d'annonce qu'on a
du mal à trier avoir où sont les
priorités ou les Pinder sales font
fondamental est-ce que c'est les grandes
questions régaliennes effectivement
est-ce que c'est au contraire la
question de l'efficacité du service
public est-ce que c'est la question de
l'écologie de l'environnement du climat
est-ce que c'est la question du travail
donc il y a une telle question de la
dette de la dette empilement c'était
parce que Emmanuel Macron avait tenté de
faire avec son allocution sur les 100
jours oui voilà alors il y a des 100
jours d'hommes les enfants l'horizont
temporel mais pour autant c'est pas
horizontal et maintenant semble aller un
peu dans toutes les dans toutes les
directions alors c'est vrai que on
n'explique pas à nouveau effectivement
pourquoi on s'appelle maintenant après
tant de projet de loi à la question qui
sont de l'immigration qui n'est pas un
point de détails et qui n'est pas du
tout perçu comme un point sur lequel
on peut improviser donc voilà et grande
pour moi grande grand problème de la
communication de l'exécutif aujourd'hui
ce sentiment de courir un peu tous les
lièvres à la fois et on ne sait plus
très bien dans quel ordre et je reprends
le l'article que vous aviez donc signé
dans la grande conversation à propos de
la réforme de retraite vous ayez une
réforme qui n'en est pas une un arbitre
le corps le conseil de rotation des
retraites qui n'en est pas un parlement
qui n'en est pas un sciences concentre
sur le Parlement
Elizabeth borne est-ce qu'elle a les
moyens de construire sur ce texte
immigration la majorité que c'est dérobé
sur les retraites dans le missiqua alors
là c'est absolument rien je pense qu'une
personne autour de cette table n'est
capable de répondre à cette question si
jamais ils ont
décidé de remettre de tenter de nouveau
là le coût c'est peut-être qu'ils ont
quelques quelques garanties mais enfin
on sait ce que valent les garanties des
des dép
donc vraiment pour moi c'est un mystère
je vous l'avoue cette cette tentative
est un mystère parce que il risque de se
retrouver exactement dans la même
situation que la réforme des retraites
avec simplement ce petit détail que
Elizabeth borne a dit qu'elle
n'utiliserait pas le 49-3 oui mais alors
là aussi elle a été quand même démentie
par par le chef de l'État juste après
oui ça a pas beaucoup bougé au sein des
députés LR non mais ils ont surtout
qu'une envie de faire ce cadeau sur
l'immigration qui considère leur
thématique qui sont déjà concurrencés
par l'Assemblée nationale ils n'ont
aucune envie de faire ce cadeau au
pouvoir donc c'est vrai que 149-3 et 100
députés LR ça va être compliqué alors il
y a toujours l'espoir au sein d'exécutif
de mettre à l'air devant ses
contradictions en disant mais regardez
on fait quasiment ce que vous voulez
quasiment la même chose que vous pas de
pause ça a pas marché pour les retraites
je voudrais qu'on reste sur cette
question
comment gouverner sans sans majorité on
peut gouverner par décret par exemple
alors c'est exactement ce que fait le
gouvernement en ce moment parce que
regardez la réforme du lycée
professionnel c'est une réforme qui n'a
pas besoin de passer par le Parlement
les grandes annonces de Gabriel Attal
sur la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
pas besoin de passer par par le
Parlement alors je pense que c'est du
bricolage politique ça ne peut pas durer
éternellement à un moment donné il va
bien falloir voter le budget là il y a
le 49-3 parce que on a le droit de le
faire visiblement sur le budget mais par
exemple la loi de programmation
militaire la loi de programmation
énergétique il y a des grandes lois qui
doivent être votées pour pouvoir mettre
la France sur les rails de la transition
énergétique d'un côté et de la et de la
nouvelle donne
géopolitique et de la guerre en Europe
de l'autre donc
ça peut se faire on le voit ça il y a
des choses qui peuvent être faites mais
est-ce que l'on peut gouverner pendant
quatre ans sans véritablement légiférer
ça c'est une question
à cette question
on peut pas il y a un moment donné il y
a un principe de réalité
qui est que malgré que nos institutions
mettent au cœur de tout le pouvoir
exécutif il y a quand même un moment
donné un principe de réalité on ne peut
pas renvoyer à la population à l'image
donc gouvernement qui n'utilise que des
instruments qui
qui tordent un petit peu le bras au
débat au débat parlementaire donc
d'autant que on parle de la réforme des
retraites et l'un des principaux points
de crispation sur la réforme des
retraites c'est plus à la limite la
question du modus opérandit et de la
démocratie que même à la limite la
question des retraites aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la suite
plusieurs fois ici le mouvement a changé
du délit de démocratie d'un pouvoir
présidentiel qui qui ne sait pas
respecter la représentation nationale
donc c'est un sujet sur lequel ils ont
une marge de manœuvre qui est serrée et
d'ailleurs à propos c'est intéressant
leur Salvat de voir la semaine prochaine
les syndicats vont venir à la table de
négociation on peut se dire à quel point
le gouvernement est dans la main des
syndicats dans dans ce dossier c'est
quand même assez passionnant en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'effectivement
d'une heure ou deux heures bon voire
moins
parce que pour le moment ils annoncent
effectivement que si on ne parle pas des
retraites voilà ça ne les intéresse
d'avoir déjà entendu
et puis il y a quand même une stratégie
de la part du gouvernement d'essayer de
désunifier ce ce
contre-pouvoir et cette opposition
syndicale parce que finalement dans la
réforme des retraites et dans la
contestation contre la réforme de
retraite c'est vraiment les syndicats
et le RN mais je dirais un peu par
défaut qui sortent gagnant le RN parce
qu'en fait ils se sont quasiment pas
positionnés ils ont dit non dès le
départ et puis après ils se sont retirés
les autres partis politiques vraiment ou
plutôt mal joué et ont plutôt affiché
des signes de division ce qui n'est
jamais très très positif en tout cas qui
est déjà est très perçu de façon
positive par l'opinion en revanche les
syndicats avec cette union syndicale qui
était assez exceptionnelle ils ont
clairement ils ont revenu sur le devant
de la scène alors qu'on les avait
enterrés depuis un moment allez dernier
chapitres de ce débat 100% poétique on
va parler de de l'interdiction des
manifestations d'ultra-droites Mathieu
et on
rembobine un peu ça démarre samedi
dernier avec cette manifestation dans la
rue de Paris oui parce qu'on a assisté à
un grand écart suivi d'un salto arrière
digne d'un numéro d'acrobate ou de
cirque selon qu'on est pour contre le
gouvernement peut-être non en fait je
récapitule samedi dernier d'abord
quelques centaines de manifestations
d'ultra droite ont donc défilé pépère
dans les rues du sixième arrondissement
parisien toute croix politique dehors et
scandant Europe jeunesse Révolution le
cri de ralliement de tous les fachos
vétie de noir masquer pour certains le
crâne rasé pour beaucoup ce petit monde
commémorer en fait la disparition en
1994 d'un de leurs congénères lors d'une
manifestation non autorisée et dans le
cortège on a trouvé beaucoup de gens qui
militer autrefois augusent vous savez le
groupe Union défense syndicat n'est la
faculté d'Assas et qui faisait le coup
de poing avec ce qu'ils appelaient les
gauchistes et pour beaucoup tout ce
petit monde là a terminé sa journée par
un concert de rock nazi dans une salle
baptisée Simone Veil dans les Yvelines
voilà ça c'était samedi dernier lundi
dernier ensuite on a Emmanuel Macron
dans l'ancienne prison de Montluc à Lyon
célébrant l'esprit de résistance et la
mémoire de Jean Moulin bref je vous fais
pas un dessin peut-on laisser défiler
des nostalgiques du Troisième Reich le
samedi et commémorer la résistance à la
barbarie nazi le lundi
la réponse est dans la question ça c'est
pour le grand écart et pour le salto
arrière c'est qu'on a d'abord eu droit à
des explications pour le moins alambiqué
attaqué par la gauche furieuse de voir
qu'on laissait défiler le guide alors
qu'on interdisait les casseroles le
préfet de police a d'abord publié un
communiqué puis est venu nous expliquer
en personne qu'on ne pouvait pas
interdire de manifestations a priori que
celle-ci c'était passé plutôt sans
débordement et que c'était même utile de
la laisser se dérouler du point de vue
du renseignement afin de savoir qui
était et ceux qui s'y disait mais
l'argumentation n'aura tenu que 24
heures le temps que la polémique monte
encore plus fort le temps qu'il aura
fallu à Gérald Darmanin pour lâcher son
préfet et annoncer que désormais il
demanderait assez préfets d'interdire
toute manifestation d'ultra-droite ou
l'extrême droite en amont donc ce qui
était pas possible avant hier devient
possible aujourd'hui à charge toutefois
et c'est un gros bémol pour les
tribunaux de juger si la jurisprudence
permet de tenir ses manifestations ou
non ça c'est pour le salto arrière
quelle conclusion peut-on en tirer avec
les exclusive a perdu sur tous les
tableaux en laissant faire en donnant du
grain à moudre à la gauche dans les
clipsant le discours présentiel sur la
résistance par une polémique sur des
néonazis dans la rue de Paris ancramant
un préfet et en prenant une décision qui
risque de ne pas toujours être appliquée
chapeau les artistes on se pose la
question dans ce débat merci Mathieu
d'un gouvernement qui navigue à vue
Bruno cotresses vous voyez dans ce voilà
dans cette séquence à notre voie c'est
quoi de tergiversation
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
effectivement qui est une une
communication qui donne le sentiment
d'un pilotage à vue ou on parlait tout à
l'heure un peu du gouvernement de
l'émotion en tout cas d'un gouvernement
qui a un pilotage un peu à vue
effectivement qui a du qui a du mal à
afficher alors là c'est vraiment
spectaculaire puisque ça conduit quand
même des aveux d'un préfet c'est pas
rien d'autant que ce préfet pour le
moment à un parcours assez sans faute on
va dire qu'il incarne une nouvelle
manière de s'y prendre avec la question
du matin de l'ordre public donc
effectivement c'est assez significatif
effectivement on attend la polémique
n’est sans doute pas fini parce que ceux
qui se verront interdire vont sans doute
porter devant les tribunaux et donc la
question n'est pas n'est pas terminée
Jean-Louis il faut peut-être rappeler
que la raison pour laquelle le préfet de
police a autorisé cette manifestation
c'est qu'il avait été déçu par le
tribunal administratif pour une
interdiction de manifestation d'extrême
droite qu'il avait décidé et le tribunal
avait dit que il n'y avait aucune raison
particulière d'interdire cette
manifestation et donc je vais défendre
quand même le préfet de police en la
matière il n'a rien fait d'autre comme
au fonctionne comme le haut
fonctionnaire qu'il est que de respecter
une décision de justice c'est-à-dire que
il a il a observé que la nouvelle
manifestation était de même nature que
celle qui avait été autorisée par le
tribunal et il a dit je n'ai pas les
moyens juridiques d'interdire cette
manifestation et donc là on voit bien à
quel point notre pays est en train un
peu de de partir un peu dans les dans
les tours si j'ose dire parce que
qu'est-ce qu'a fait le ministre de
l'Intérieur il a dit j'interdis
systématiquement et je laisse les
tribunaux décider de savoir si j'ai
raison ou tort donc si vous voulez il y
a là quand même quelque chose d'assez
étrange parce que si jamais un haut
fonctionnaire ou un ministre n'est pas
capable d'évaluer la probabilité d'une
d'un démenti judiciaire on rentre dans
un autre monde par rapport à celui que
nous avons connu nous dans l'ancien
monde j'espère que il faut dire c'est à
dire que à partir du moment où on est
capable d'évaluer une situation et bien
on prend une décision politique qui ne
risque pas d'être démenti par un juge
alors l'absence de risque identifié de
troubles à l'ordre public c'est aussi
l'argument qui a utilisé Elizabeth borde
pour justifier le fait d'avoir laissé
cette manifestation se dérouler
je conçois que ces images les plus
choquées et simplement je rappelle que
dans notre pays il y a un droit à
manifester qui est garantie et qu'on ne
peut
revenir sur ce droit que quand il y a
des bonnes raisons qui sont énumérées
dans la loi par exemple des risques de
troubles à l'ordre public il se trouve
qu'il n'y avait pas de risques identifié
d'autant que cette manifestation a déjà
eu lieu des années passées et qu'elles
ne s'était pas traduite par des troubles
à l'ordre public donc il n'y ait pas de
motif pour interdire cette manifestation
donc dans ce cas là c'est la liberté de
manifester qui prévaut
effectivement ce sentiment Mathieu
l'évoquait un petit peu de deux poids de
mesure d'un côté les casseroles
d'interdites de l'autre une
manifestation d'extrême droite autorisée
je pense aussi qu'il y a ce sentiment de
surréaction à l'actualité c'est à dire
que dès qu'il y a un fait d'actualité
qui intervient tout le gouvernement se
met en branle pour pour réagir et donc
c'est là aussi où on voit d'accord avec
vous mais c'est franchement sont pas
nouveau quoi c'est je connais pas un
gouvernement qui est pas fait ça depuis
que je m'intéresse à la politique
dans d'autres circonstances elle elle
serait passée inaperçue il faut il faut
quand même le je crois que les
circonstances jouent un rôle important
exactement
à une léonarda enfin bon non mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire si on doit
commencer à aller chercher dans les dans
les surréactions de de de gouvernement
c'est un président de la République
quand même mais non je crois je crois
aussi qu'on voit bien à quel point
l'opinion est était ruptive c'est-à-dire
que à la à la moindre manifestation
effectivement de quelque chose qui
pourrait troubler l'ordre public
effectivement il y a des réactions
extrêmement vives Emmanuel Macron
justement et avait promis en tout cas
d'essayer de sortir de cette politique
réaction en disant le covid la guerre en
Ukraine j'ai été obligé de faire de la
politique réaction et là je voudrais
faire plutôt de la politique
d'anticipation de la politique de projet
etc et là on voit en fait que au
quotidien il a du mal à sortir de ça ça
renforce ce sentiment sur lequel on
débat depuis un an de difficultés
d'absence de cap ou de difficultés à
donner le sentiment qu'on donne à un cap
aux Français peut-être une question
Bruno cotress s'être ultra droite là va
aussi différente et cagoulé que que l'on
a vu en démonstration est-ce qu'elle
fait en creux le jeu de Marine Le Pen et
de ses députés sages écrasés
ce que certains c'est que le
rassemblement national depuis au moins
l'élection présidentielle de 2022 et
clairement dans une stratégie de
normalisation et de recherche de
crédibilité présidentielle et
gouvernementale et Marine Le Pen a de
cesse de d'envoyer un message à dans
cette dans cette direction et d'ailleurs
lorsqu'elle a été amenée à par des
questions des questions de journalistes
à savoir si elle connaissait des membres
de ce groupe elle a dit qu'elle n'avait
rien à voir avec elle était un peu en
difficulté d'ailleurs de ce point de vue
là donc c'est vrai que dans cette
stratégie de crédibilité de crédibilité
gouvernementale en particulier
Marine Le Pen a le rassemblement
national la rigoureusement aucun intérêt
à montrer le moindre signe de connivence
avec ce type de groupuscule Marine Le
Pen dit depuis des semaines quel
peut-être qu'elle tire profite cette
séquence des retraites mais si on voit
les résultats des législatives
partielles c'est pas aussi évident
jean-louisika donc vous avez raison les
législatives partielles naturellement
initiative partielle il faut faire très
attention on est prudent il y a très peu
de participation
nationale j'aurais dû dire ça pour
démarrer c'est c'est très difficile d'en
tirer des enseignements dans des
enseignements généraux pour l'ensemble
pour l'ensemble du pays mais enfin ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'il y a un décalage
mais je crois que vraiment on se
décalage
il est il est vraiment lié à à ce que
moi j'appelle le nouveau régime
médiatique c'est-à-dire que les
polémiques la stratégie du clash avec
les chaînes d'opinion avec avec les
réseaux sociaux fait qu'on a
l'impression d'une France à feu et à 100
d'une France au bord de la crise de
nerfs alors qu'en réalité l'opinion
publique n'est pas vraiment dans cet
état d'esprit l'opinion publique est
beaucoup plus calme beaucoup plus modéré
au sens large là je parle sur le
contrôle de leurs alevins
je cherche à démontrer quand il va sur
le terrain et qu'il fait une escale non
prévu pour pas se retrouver face à la
majorité face à uniquement des
casseroles de toute façon les casseroles
elles sont toujours là parce que
elles font partie de ce nouveau régime
de ce nouveau régime médiatique mais en
revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que quand
on regarde les résultats des élections
mais quand on regarde aussi certains
sondages d'opinion on se rend compte que
la France modérée existe et qu'elle a et
qu'elle a de beaux jours devant elle oui
puis on se rend compte effectivement que
qui a pas de dégringolade de l'opinion à
l'égard de d'Emmanuel Macron et là
plutôt dans les derniers baromètres le
nôtre comme ceux de nos collègues et ben
Emmanuel Macron soit il se stabilise
soit il progresse un petit peu dans
l'opinion c'est à dire que bon bah voilà
il y a aussi cette idée quand même que
quelque part la réforme des retraites
aussi est passée je pense aussi que les
Français ont envie de passer à autre
chose et je suis d'accord assez d'accord
avec Jean-Louis pour dire qu'il y a
comment dire comme une dissonance entre
le bruit médiatique et puis finalement
nous quand on explore l'opinion on se
dit c'est pas tout à fait quand même
érupti sur tous les sujets
un dernier mot Bruno c'est pas eruptif
mais par contre c'est avec plein
d'interrogations plein de questions un
sentiment un peu de perte de sens de
confusion qui est très important quand
même un sentiment de confusion qui est
très important de plus savoir très bien
où on est avec une communication
vraiment telle qui doit se moduler là
quand même du mal à tracer une un chemin
très clair et très bien balisé pour
l'opinion grâce à vous nous on essaye de
donner du sens à l'actualité donc je
sais pas si on y arrive mais on essaye
non mais juste je suis entièrement
d'accord est-ce qu'il vient dire Bono
simplement il y a aussi quand même dans
la part de l'opinion une certaine un
certain recul par rapport à ce bruit
médiatique et et je sais plus quel est
l'institut qui a fait ce sondage qui
montrait que plus de 50% des français
disent ressentir une fatigue
informationnelle et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même assez
intéressant parce que on voit bien que
on est confronté à un vrai problème
d'organisation du débat public
aujourd'hui en France bon prendre le
temps d'un débat apaisé c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire Mathieu tous les jours
dans cette dans cette émission
merci à tous merci d'avoir participé à
ce premier débat Jean-Louis Sika je
renvoie à la lecture de votre article et
de tous les autres qui sont publiés dans
la revue la grande
conversation et c'est gratuit et c'est
gratuit bah voilà le message est passé
publicité gratuite